a million cases in just
two weeks and yet life in the cities
is getting back to normal the government
is keen to avoid a repeat of
march when india suffered what was then
the toughest lockdown
in the world the 21-day stoppage
saved lives but battered the economy
output shrank by almost a quarter in the
summer
millions lost their jobs now with many
businesses on the brink of ruin
a renewed shutdown would be devastating
recent university graduate ravi chand
says the pandemic is robbing both young
and old of their
there are no futures here in the city or
in rural areas
all you hear about is people getting
fired hardly anyone is hiring
recent graduates either can't find jobs
or they're being fired
the hotel industry has been hit the
hardest many older workers are losing
their jobs
the government has launched a mass
awareness campaign encouraging the
public to wear masks
wash their hands and maintain physical
distance
but not everyone is heeding the call
lots of people aren't wearing masks but
you really have to now
everyone needs to think about their
health at this point
people just don't understand
winter and india's festival season are
approaching
that means huge gatherings in temples
and shopping districts
if the world's biggest democracy is to
get on top of the pandemic
persuading the public to mask up will be
crucial for more on this let's cross
over to dw
correspondent manira chowdhury in delhi
manira the virus
is still spreading at an alarming pace
people seem to be getting more and more
frustrated as we've just seen
health health experts rather a warning
about mask
and distancing fatigue just how big a
problem is that
well india at this very point is just a
few weeks away from
becoming the worst hit country for this
pandemic in the world we are just behind
the us as you just mentioned
and the fatigue that the experts are
pointing out at is actually a serious
condition
the removal of restrictions which had
become important after months of
nationwide lockdown
to resume economy because economy did
did have a major fallout after the
lockdown
has resulted in a sense of normalcy
coming back on the streets and that
sense of normalcy has
resulted in a sense of complacency also
amongst people so if you go out on the
streets you do see that
not enough distances are being
maintained and while even in bigger
cities like delhi and mumbai you can see
people on the street
wearing masks if you go to the suburban
areas or the smaller towns you don't
even see that
and while people are wearing masks and
that also is out of fear of getting
fined by the police
they're not wearing the mask properly or
wearing the correct kind of mask so
there is a sense of fatigue which has
set in
right and with almost 75 000 new covert
cases being reported daily it's quite
alarming but how reliable
are those figures
well if you if you listen to the experts
if you look at a lot of reports being
done then
yes there is a possibility that the
actual number of cases are actually much
higher than what is being reported per
day
there have also been reports from
smaller towns of under reporting
the cases and under reporting at the
deaths which are happening due to
corvette so the actual number may
actually be much higher
also because our the testing for core
within india continues to remain low
uh compared to many other countries and
when i say that our testing continues to
remain low we have to look at it
in context of the population that we
have a 1.3 billion people and the
population density that we have
and of course winter is on the way as
well as the hindu festival season just
briefly
what will that mean for the numbers
well experts and the government is also
saying that there is a risk of the
numbers increasing because
corona virus is actually a respiratory
virus essentially and
the possibilities of transmission of
this virus during winters during cold
weather
actually much higher and besides we do
have a major festival coming
in just a few weeks in india and
traditionally while during this festival
people throng the local markets and they
meet each other
even though we can expect that that that
level of meetup is not going to happen
this year but there is still a chance of
the numbers seeing the spike during that
festive season
all right monero chowdhury in delhi
thanks very much for the update
you